Oh gon read my name and welcome to I can
finally I've been told I stood too close
to the camera so it's awkward I'm so I'm
sorry for the awkward mesh it's gonna be
difficult when I brofist though all
right so that intro was made by Miller
x11 may ml or twelve well done bro you
can submit your video every week as a
video response if you want your video to
be in the intro also try to be creative
do it could be whatever like it could be
used singing or jumping down from the
hill I don't know why it would do that
but I'm DJing if you want her you could
do it please I'm doing first and
foremost I guess it wasn't really fun
but I want to thank you brother from the
bottom of my heart there you go thank
you to everyone who voted so far in the
king of web
I know it's had its up-and-down ups and
downs we still got 1500 years of
American dollars towards charity I think
that's pretty damn good if I take him at
home as I and King Kong who have decided
since all of this mess I suppose that
they're gonna match that amount and
donate it to WWF as well so we should
count this as a victory to 3,000 us
American dollars for the Tigers and I
think that's pretty impressive Congrats
to vdf and all the other winners of cars
I wasn't actually gonna plan to do this
I'm still not sure if it's a good idea
but because I really didn't want to
since all the things that happen but I
don't know I posted it on my facebook I
asked you bros should I run for it again
apparently if you win one time you can't
do it again so and it was a pretty
unanimous decision that you bros wanted
to crown me king of the web so i don't
know what it is but so let's grab our
torches unless ray dish
I'm just kidding let's see if we can be
too many wells this time and let's get
your money out for to charity yes of
course I will be donating the money to
charity as well since part of the prize
award was $500 for game stop [ __ ]
game stop I I'm not really a I'm a PC
gamer I don't buy a game and buy games
but not hard copy that's what she's know
that didn't make so I was thought might
not give it away to you bros as a thanks
for helping me and crowning me to keep
this king of the web thing so this I
thought each week I'll give away one
game and we'll start with kingdoms of
Alamo I play this game it is freaking
awesome
so I don't know leave a comment if you
want this game tell me why you want it
and I don't try to be too cheesy could
add too much cheese is never delicious
also I got a new YouTube background
they're changing their frigging channel
but anyway I gotta do you want its
Messiah I made it for me a really good
job go check him out in the description
if you're interested in the design stuff
I hope you bros like a new camera as
always we're gonna end up with a bro
fish um thank you both for everything
you do to me all the crazy stuff you do
I think this Kevin king of the web
competition showed pretty well freaking
awesome you are
I definitely look so awkward standing it
this King won that competition him
really showed how amazing you bros are
with all your support I think everyone
was impressed by like us competing
against someone who has like 1 million 1
million fans on phase we have we are
what like 46,000 it's pretty crazy so
stay awesome bros and three all right 3
2 1
[Music]